지금 부동산 경기가 굉장히 안
좋잖아요. 오피스 안 죽고 뭐 상가
다 죽어 있는데 사실 관점만 바꿔
보시면 굉장히 고수위게 앞으로 3,
40년간 임차인 걱정 안 해도 되는
굉장히 좋은 상품이기 때문에 고민하지
마시고 일산남에 연락 주시면은 굉장히
좋은 상품 될 것 같습니다. 네.
>> 네. 안녕하세요. 여기가 어디냐면
용인의 실버타운으로 운영하는 곳에 좀
와 있습니다. 지금 뒤에 보이는이
건물을 저희가 투어를 할 예정인데
과연 요즘에 실버타운을 [음악]
어떻게 만들었고 어떤 수익이 나고
과연 운영이 가능할지를 제가 오늘
직접 가서 거기 대표님이랑 [음악]
뭐 인터뷰를 좀 해 보도록 할 건데
오늘 영상을 좀 유심히 보시면 좋을
것 같습니다. 가시죠.
저희 스위트룸인데 혼자 거주하시는
방이에요.
>> 아
너무 좋다.
>> 보시면 딱 집처럼 돼 있어요. 어신
원래 사시던 집류 가져가고 계시고
원래 쓰시는 화장품 요양원이 아닌
거죠. 본인이 쓰시는 있고
>> 요양원이 법적으로 [음악] 보통 두세
평이에요. 근데 요양원의 1인시에
두세 평이라고 하면 생각해 보시면
움직이지 말라가 컨셉이거든요.
>> 아 이게 사실 눕는 데밖에 없잖아요.
오션처럼. 그러면은 어르신들의 삶이
없어요. 그 저희는 법정 사이즈보다
훨씬 크게 한 거예요. 친구도 오게끔
하고 쉬기도 하고 일기도 쓰고
[음악] 내짐도 넣을 수 있는 공간을
때 그게 최소 여덟평에서 1평 정도는
나와야 된다가 저희 생각이어서 다른
이제 시설 대비 훨씬 공간이 크게
되어 있는 거죠.
여기가 이제 복도를 따라서 각 세대가
있고요. 지금 사시는 공간이 있고
여기가 각 친구별로 공용부가 있어요.
시금하고 프로그램하면서 더 친해지고
또
>> 여기서 상주하는 요양보사께서
모니터링하고 관리해 드리고
>> 여기 또 식사하시고 싶으면 여기서
식사하게끔 하고 또 식사도 이제
친구랑 먹고 싶기도 한데 개인이 먹고
싶기도 하잖아요. 또 방에 사서
하게끔 그렇게 돼 있어요. 가 이제
가장 큰 공용부 단체 식사도
>> 하고 단체 프로그램도 하고 재활도
오셔서 하게끔 되는 거고 조격을
어르신들이 좋아하시잖아요. 그 조격을
같이 할 수 있게끔 되어 있고
결국에는 조격을 통해서 체온을 높여서
면역력을 높이는 프로그램들 그런 거
하고 있습니다.
>> 여기가 저희
>> 찜질방찜
>> 체온이 높아지면 면형이 높아져요.
일반적으로는 표피만 높여서 체온
높이면 한계가 있는데 빛을 신부까지
써 주면 안에서부터 면역이 높아지기
때문에 매뉴 프로그램 운영하는 공간이
>> 여기가 저희가 사우나인데 일반적
사우나태 돼 있고
>> 어떻게 보시면은 작다고 볼 수
있는데네이
>> 정도면 충분하죠.
>> 네.
>> 작은게 아니라 개인 사우나라고
보시면은 다시 엄청 큰 거예요. 온탕
링탕 이렇게 스팟까지
>> 아
>> 여기는 이제 물리 치료시죠.
어르신들이 연세가 들면 상하지 끝으로
피부가 잘 안 통해요. 발에 체온도
높여주고 마사지도 해서 그 전기적으로
>> 하게끔 되어 있고 또 여기가 물리
치료사가 있어요.
>> 오셔서 이제 전담으로 1대일 PTS
물리치료 PT도 받기도 하고 요런
것도 할 수 있는 공간입니다.
>> 아 이렇게
>> 네
>> 세탁기랑 건조이 같이 있네요. 세탁도
저희가 다 도와드리고 보시면은 목욕도
아까 개인 목욕실에서 해도 되는데
>> 네네
식사도 저희 직접해요.
>> 아 직접해요?네 네. 그니까 식자재만
삼성거를 받아서 쓰고 있고요. 식당
운영과 돌인 직접해야 결국에는
어르신들 식사에 대한 퀄리티의 요구나
입맛이 다 까드럽잖아요. 근데 그걸
위탁을 져버리면 관리가 되더로 안
돼요. 그 수요를 저희가 직접 다
반영해서 입맛을 하나하나 맞추는
겁니다. 그
>> 또 고려야 되는 거는 저희가 또 전담
영양 사분이 계셔 가지고 못 드시는
거 알러지 음식 이런 것들도 다
반영해야 되기 때문에 그런 것도 다
관리를 하는
>> 그 마진이 있습니다. 간이 짜다.
맛이 없다. 비용이 이제 평당 조금
안 되게 그냥
>> 너무 싼데 생각보다